he's here not only on behalf of just
himself and being just a great human
being but we're gonna talk about his new
his new company defy and what that's all
about
he's talked about it before of let's
talk about it again he's told Davis how
are you TD talking to you you want ask
Terrell Davis the poll question Chris
Brockman since we're here a really good
time with it today cuz SpaceX I'm if you
see that we're launching human beings
into space today asking the question
Chris alright Edie would you want to go
into space unforgettable experience yes
or no after 30 seconds then what yeah
I'm more of the uh probably not
am I like I don't have a fascination
with outer space and going to a planet
or somewhere where people it's just not
been there never been there enough time
to tell me exactly what's happening so
no I'm not that intrigued to go to go to
space
let's get full disclosure gotta get to
full disclosure then is it because of
your we've have seen T D versus gravity
that has happened before
no and you passed out flying with the
Blue Angels this has nothing to do with
that experience it's not even that
number one I was flown in plat flown
with the Thunderbirds I've flown but
Bill's right doesn't my second time
playing with them and you know what the
mission was
the minute I went up there the pilot he
told we're up this one hour and he wore
me out and he tried to he tried to he
got me he caught me slipping or not
working we were coming in land a plane
and he told me he said listen are you
are you are you up what to do one more
but no I said you know and not really
you know I'm kind of worn out he said oh
no it's only about a 1/2 G turn so don't
worry about it and I was like alright
cool whatever you know if that's the
case then didn't do it
he pulled a 7g turn on I would even
ready for it and he put me to sleep
we can't be sitting there you know what
everybody everybody get caught slippin
every once in a while
did you give the pilot of talking to
Terrell Davis once you came to what
Super Bowl was that act that you did it
for anything you know that was the one
that was in Arizona you know the
Steelers Steelers and and the Cardinals
was in Tampa that that probably was the
Patriots going for the perfect season
versus the giant TD because it because
we have been showing that every single
time for a Super Bowl thereafter when
John Elway pays a visit like if anybody
wants to see another human being laugh
at a great friends expense it's when
John John Elway we would show it to him
and he would like you can't even use the
word cackle to describe what he did
would delight and glitter to the point
where he would then come on and request
it yes to see that video yeah I'm sorry
to bring it up TD you expect this to be
brought up we're talking about manned
space flight how are you doing otherwise
everybody good in your neck of the woods
life's good everybody healthy right now
buddies well anybody else just gonna
figure out when we'll be able to get
back into the normal routine but
everybody I'm glad to hear that I'm very
very glad to hear that what do you think
of the bra I like the Broncos draft Tee
tee I like what your your guy Elway did
I think they're building do we call this
sneaky good offense I mean when you've
got when you've got the running back
group that they have
um yeah and they you you have jury duty
now I mean yeah I kind of like with
hammer right now what do you think III
agree I agree I think this is a new you
get a sense from the way the season
ended last year where you got you know
Locke who kind of opened some eyes up
and really got the confidence and and
the teammates and his teammates excited
about him as a quarterback and as you
know for many years Denver has been
looking for that guy so I think he's not
only showing it on the field but I think
his personality in the locker room it's
really comfortable and I think that's
what people are looking at when you have
a guy that has an infectious personality
that is able to connect with it with the
players and still going to feeling it
before at the same time I mean actually
close you and he seems to have he seems
to have that it factor you know when the
game is on a line he seems to be called
anything and he seems like he might be
that guy so I think the Bronco country
is really excited about that
and you talked about ego Drive Jerry
Judy first round I get Kate hammer in a
second then they drafted I'll go home
and the fourth round so they're putting
a lot of weapons around this young
quarterback and then you go out there
and get mill and gore in this region
which I like the reason like Milken
gorgeous Kentucky's a veteran running
back any pay a lot to get them and any
time you can get depth in this you know
and its lead and have running back
running backs that's a little different
and skill sets it's always a plus so
yeah man I'm pretty excited about dinner
looks like this year and uh but it's
gonna play out man uniting that division
with Kansas City so oh yeah yeah
point point after you gotta go out there
be are be a team that's the inter vivos
will be good but I think to kind of come
back with Kansas City is doing you gotta
have it all plus Melvin Gordon's gonna
have a chip certainly against the
Chargers in the two times they save they
take him on how do you how do you see
the the splits going running back with
Phillip Lindsey and Melvin and there and
the rest of the crew what do you think I
don't know because a lot of times it's a
feel for game you know it's a game game
plan specific you know
it's risky because you have guys with
two different skills that I imagine it's
gonna start off with Melbourne been you
know the first the first second nail
back but if the package is there if
they're running a wide open offense
maybe it includes don't Lindsey a little
bit more in that but I don't know how
they're gonna divide that the reps up it
might just be by feel and the hot mangas
to get to get the potato and I don't
know
Terrell Davis here on the Rich Eisen
show all right did you see the the last
dance you check that one out what do you
think of the whole conversation about
Jordans demeanor with his teammates in
his leadership skills and the way he he
went about it yeah I think people were a
little surprised by it because unless to
see it from the inside you look at I
think he see Michael Jordan in a
different light I mean he was brutal
I mean he was hard on a lot of his
teammates but I'm not surprised by that
and that's him
I've seen that with with great leaders
and actually I would really talented
players he wants to be great and he
expects everybody else to be the same
way and he held them to a standard and
held them accountable and it might have
been out his style diffident what I
would how I use my leadership style but
that's the way Michael Jordan felt he
had motivated players and I wasn't like
a lot of people like men know it's a lot
of people work and it kind of getting
kind of in their eyes it might have
diminished Michael Jordan's kind of this
the stellar image that yet but you
didn't take away from my standpoint and
take away from the way I see Michael
George well I mean the thing that got me
I didn't change the way I looked at
Jordan either but no not at all I mean
shoot you saw me in episode 10 with hair
I mean I was covering I know you saw
that right I was covering it I was calm
I was the guy sitting next to Stuart
Scott so I couldn't get a sniff for the
Georgia highlights on SportsCenter I
couldn't even do that so no I didn't
change my opinion of him at all
it's him saying everyone off its 24
hours a day
and to this day even two but no the
thing that that got me is that he said
if you disagreed with it I'm
paraphrasing here then you haven't won
anything and you know there's been a lot
of guys maybe he didn't win six and lose
zero in the opportunities that that he
made it to the finals but I mean he did
get knocked off before he won his first
three-peat and then he did you know come
back to the point where he wasn't
physically able to compete for a
championship before another three-peat
but I mean like what you know what is
Elway like you know I mean what I always
it go like that not like that right what
was he like what was he like different
just different leadership styles let me
know that and there's different players
who they play different roles
you know John's leadership style was
more of he was more money he was gonna
go play and and ball out and that's the
way he led and he would rarely same
thing any be said conference you know
was very significant I mean it meant
something but it might be the fact
there's two different sports to I'm
because we hear Kobe Bryant was pretty
yes no verbal about his leadership style
and in football you got so many players
like you're not gonna be out there on
top and everybody like that that is too
much going on but John was John was
about handling his business leading by
example if you had to say something to
you he would but for John man we're just
giving a feel with him the presence of
John Elway he made me have to play
better I had to gain his respect that
and make sure that I didn't mess up I
thought I was coming to bring my a-game
every time I played because I had an
answer to him and you didn't wanna you
couldn't you didn't want to let him down
you felt like he had more more authority
then the coaches like Peyton Manning
when Peyton Manning on the field now you
feel like that's the person that I have
to block at a plate this guy otherwise
I'm not gonna be in a tunnel and so that
was different leadership style but yeah
I wasn't I wasn't shocked by it
yeah you know Mandy yeah I know and you
know I mentioned that to Shaq when he
came on and Shaq's like what do you
think I was like you know like you know
that that it's not just you know
specific to Michael that there's a
certain demanding quality that you know
you would think maybe every
hall-of-famer has it you know but that's
the difference fingering great an
all-time great in many people's minds
right and and certainly excuse it if
it's particularly rough when it results
in six championships and no losses and
six NBA Finals you know yeah for coaches
too rich I mean there's coaches who make
that they don't by the time you tell
might be like Bill Parcells he was rough
like he was straight to let you listen
to being on Bill Belichick and how his
style is and then you have some coaches
like you know my Santa hat who wasn't
like that or you you know Pete Carroll
or some other coaches they have these
different styles and you know as long as
you're winning and you're successful
people will excuse it they were like
okay you know he's rough he's a little
abrasive but he's winning and got their
attention and people just accept it
Terrell Davis here in the Rich Eisen
show we've been talking about how people
do their business let's talk about your
business I'll give you the floor and
defy and what it is and how people could
seek it out for some help yeah the forum
is a CBD performance drink and it has
zero THC in it we've been around for is
our anniversary was was a week ago
21st yeah we made the one year at the
end right you know like you're like in a
coconut water
B vitamins I was really helpful you to
perform needs a name recover it's a
really good pre-workout post-workout
drink we are we just lost our the five
zero which is coming out next
week you can get ourself at drink to
five calm it's really helped me on then
I've been on on CBD for three years now
and it's really allowed me to to be able
to work out harder recover faster
inflammations gone pain is gone it's
really been to me has been a life
altering experience and that's why I was
able to even my team and we develop defy
and so we were pretty proud about it man
so check us out again during the
fighting on up and we did was doing this
pandemic we were able to donate over
four hundred thousand dollars worth of
products amazing feat in America
throughout this country so we try to do
our part and you know it's try to give
back when we could and we really thought
you could do it to help you with your
migraines cheating how often you have
those still yeah
so the other thing that I didn't expect
was you know I've been have a migraine
since out nine years old and I've
substituted on my migraine preventative
medicine which was a anti-inflammatory
for my product or the TV time taken and
so the last two years we have used now
I've had one migraine and so that that's
been remarkable and I was like a half
migraine so it really worked as an
anti-inflammatory to help me prevent and
manage my migraines and I have been more
than thrilled that that has been the
case because I did not expect that
I won't even thinking about that John
read more research about that in and
there was some tomorrow cause and some
research that suggested that that it can
help with migraines and yeah and it's
been so that's that's really been the
key for me man
has there been any research from you or
your team about how define what could
help anybody stay conscious during a7g
turn that a pilot turns on a dime let
you know what we come up with I have
been told during the process so what
would your answer about the face of
course I go into space
are you kidding we gonna wait why would
why wouldn't I why not I do what
there's what if you have mechanical
issues and you can't get back to earth
are you cool with that I mean you fine
with that see know we had all things
being equal situation dirt all right
that I would be first of all you want
target you want talk reality I'm not
passing a physical to be sent into space
right now it's a fifty year old man
you're you it you were part of the
original 40-yard dash TD you've bet
you've got a front-row seat okay yeah so
I mean if you want to bring in reality
to this I'm just saying what I want to
go I said yes
I turn to Chris Brockman with whom I
think I share a kinship and a similar
sensibility of life and every now and
then he'll turn up and up and say
something dumb like yeah but I go up
then what and I'm like what do you mean
like I feel how old are your kids
TD okay how many times you have to tell
your kids just look out the window when
you're driving I feel like I'm saying
that to my to a child like just look out
the window for me will be a few problems
one I'm kind of claustrophobic like I
don't want to be in this capsule that's
just that's not don'ts like it's enough
space in that thing right and then how
long is this trip it seemed like it's
really a pretty long trip how long do I
pad you know what I mean you kind of get
on it internet what can I do one well
it's funny you should ask
actually we had an astronaut yes he
watched the Super Bowl from the
International Space Station TV okay the
red zone I mean if that's what your
concern is I mean we'll get you home for
dinner
give us a few how long did the flight
how long I'd say a week a week
[Laughter]
give me a range Ltd I don't like being
on a plane for four hours by the way
I've seen you on plane jet but I like it
over your head so people don't bother
you when you fall asleep you never you
never awake on a plane I've traveled
with you you get that right that's about
a four hour trip four hours for two
hours so what if we gave you a blanket
you do your usual flight thing without
the passing out you put the thing on
your head and you go to sleep you could
probably use that wouldn't let them so
that number one I would defeat the whole
trip because wouldn't you want to see if
you're [ __ ] if you're going up there
you want to look out the window like you
said and I see the earth get smaller but
I wouldn't want to do it I mean the
first first couple of the first of hours
might be cool but I can't what you doing
up there this is a serious question if
you're claustrophobic what's it like
underneath a pile of nineteen 300-pound
men who have just tackled you you must
have gone crazy down at the bottom of
the pile that really happened that's why
you're in the Hall of Fame you avoided
contact oh I see all right Edie thanks
for the call you're the best best your
family at Tyrell underscore Davis on
Twitter at the real Terrell Davis on
Instagram to learn more about defying
just hang with TD thanks for the call
brother
you're the best that's Terrell Davis hey
you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here